Television is great for telling serialized stories
over time, but not every TV series is meant to
last. None of the shows on this list made it past
a single season — and we still aren't over it.
Pulling from their own awkward high
school experiences as newcomers and
outsiders in small communities, David
Guarascio and Moses Port recalled the
genesis of their show, Aliens in America,
in an interview with Patheos, saying,
"We [...] started talking about politics
and the giant gap that exists between
Americans and really the rest of the
world, specifically the Muslim world."
Airing on the CW between 2007 and 2008,
Aliens in America focuses on social misfit
Justin Tolchuck and his wholesome yet
quirky Wisconsin family. They take in a
foreign exchange student from Pakistan for
a culture clash comedy about "peace, love,
and understanding," as the show's theme song goes.
"Why don't you wear a warmer jacket
over that boy blouse of yours."
When Scott Patterson, who played patriarch
Gary Tolchuck, sat down with IGN in 2008,
he was full of praise for Aliens
in America's humor and its message,
calling it relevant for the times and saying,
"The beauty of the show is that it
shows there's ignorance on both sides."
Critics were fond of it, too,
even when the ratings didn't
back it up. The Boston Herald wrote that,
"Aliens in America is warm, funny,
and smart. It doesn't stand a chance."
That prediction proved true. Two years later,
Variety was still lamenting
the show's cancellation.
With the success of Star Wars came imitators
hot on its heels, hoping to turn their own
space dust into magic. In 1978, producer Glen
A. Larson tried to launch his own space opera:
Battlestar Galactica. In an interview with
Science and Fantasy Film Classics magazine,
Larson described his approach to the show:
"It's Genesis. It's basically the
concept of all the human cultures
in space having evolved from a mother
planet culture. [...] We've got a truly
rare opportunity to really open up
that frontier and talk about what
could happen out there in space. It doesn't
have to be all robots and flying machines."
"Yes, the mother world of all
humans. Where life began."
The series takes place at the end of a
long conflict between humans and Cylons,
robots created by an extinct reptilian
race. Humanity rallies behind the Galactica,
a battlestar warship led by Commander
Adama, played by Lorne Greene.
"Ready. Fire."
Things got off to a bumpy start
for the show when the premiere was
interrupted by President Jimmy Carter's
announcement of the Camp David Accords.
The good fight for humanity raged on,
but competition from other networks
and constant comparisons to Star Wars
did the show no favors. Ron Cowan from the
wrote of Battlestar Galactica at the time,
"The opening was impressive, but the show [...]
became more a soap opera than a space opera."
The writing was on the wall.
Battlestar Galactica was taken
out of orbit the following season. Many
prefer the highly acclaimed 2004 reboot,
but plenty of viewers still have a
soft spot for the original series.
Out of all the zany characters Martin Short has
brought to life, few have utilized his talents
better than buttoned-up, triangle-haired,
happy-go lucky Ed Grimley. Short debuted
the character at The Second City and Grimley was
further developed on SCTV and Saturday Night Live.
But Short wasn't interested in playing
Grimley on the big screen. Instead,
he took Hanna-Barbera up on an offer to create a
Saturday morning cartoon, The Completely Mental
Misadventures of Ed Grimley. The move made sense
because, as he told New York's The Post-Star,
"It's a real-life person acting
like an animated character."
They modeled the cartoon after The Adventures
of Rocky and Bullwinkle and Friends,
making it something both kids and parents
could enjoy. Short went tall on talent,
bringing Catherine O'Hara, Andrea Martin, and
Jonathan Winters on board to amp the absurdity.
The following season, Grimley got the ax, replaced
by fellow SCTV alum John Candy's animated show,
Camp Candy. Short bemoaned the decision in
an interview with The Tampa Tribune, saying,
"It had reviews like we wrote them ourselves,
and NBC couldn't take that show off fast enough.
They thought it was too odd. If I had done Ed
Grimley, Boy Scout Leader, it would be on today."
MC Serch, aka Michael Berrin, knows a thing or
two about what it takes to be respected as a
white rapper. In 2007, the former 3rd Bass member
hosted Ego Trip's The (White) Rapper Show on VH1.
"I was confused when I seen the
white rappers comin' down the
block. I was wonderin' what was
goin' on, you know what I mean?"
According to an interview Serch gave to The
Virginian-Pilot, the competition series mixed
elements of "Survivor, hip-hop, Jeopardy, racial
tension, political views, and Seinfeld" into one.
Ten hopeful rappers with stage
names like $hamrock, Jus Rhyme,
Persia, G-Child, and 100 Proof — lived in the
Bronx and battled for $100,000. They got to
work with hip-hop royalty like Kurtis Blow,
Prince Paul, Kool Keith, Grandmaster Flash,
and House of Pain members Danny Boy O'Connor
and Erik Francis Schrody, aka Everlast.
One contestant, Jon Boy, told The Virginian-Pilot:
"I felt like the show was rap
boot camp. It was really humbling,
trying to educate us on where hip-hop came from."
Serch was hopeful that a second season would
get greenlit, but it never materialized.
Folk comedy duo Riki Lindhome and Kate Micucci
are better known to fans as Garfunkel and
Oates. They're sometimes referred to
as the female Flight of the Conchords,
which they don't mind. In an interview with
the Tampa Bay Times, Lindhome admitted,
"We describe ourselves as that because it's
an easy way to let people know what we do."
Their naughty, sharp-tongued brand of musical
humor led HBO to develop a pilot with them,
but it never took flight. Instead, they
landed at IFC with a self-titled show,
directed and executive produced by Fred Savage.
"We can't open for our own knock-off. That's like
Paul McCartney opening for a Beatles cover band."
Playing exaggerated versions of themselves,
Lindhome and Micucci set about trying
to make it big in Hollywood. The duo
had to tone down their act to comply with the
TV-14 rating. Micucci told Under the Radar,
"Because the show's TV-14, a lot of our
dirtier material we were not able to use."
Instead, they poked fun at everything from Sesame
Street and Saved by the Bell to sports fans and,
of course, themselves. Joining in on the fun were
the likes of Tig Notaro, Kevin Pollak, 'Weird Al'
Yankovic, Kumail Nanjiani, Ben Kingsley, and even
rocker John Oates, who told Entertainment Weekly,
"I thought they were really clever and funny."
So did critics. The show dropped to
rave reviews in 2014. News of the show's
cancellation after a single season didn't go
down well. As one AV Club headline put it:
"IFC stops being cool, cancels
'Garfunkel And Oates.'"
It's hard to fathom that The Honeymooners, one of
the most iconic sitcoms of all time, lasted just a
single season. The show that CBS first beamed onto
black-and-white TV sets in 1955 set the standard
for television comedy for decades, influencing
everything from The Flintstones to King of Queens.
The show originated as a sketch on Jackie
Gleason's variety show Cavalcade of Stars in
1951. The domestic antics of Gleason's bus driver
character, Ralph Kramden, followed Gleason to The
Jackie Gleason Show and would eventually
become the basis for a half hour comedy.
"I don't know anybody does the mambo.
I don't do it. Norton doesn't do
it. My grandmother never did it."
Although The Honeymooners trailed
The Perry Como Show in the ratings,
CBS was hungry for more. Alas, Gleason
turned them down. The star is quoted
in William J. Weatherby's Jackie Gleason: An
Intimate Portrait of the Great One as saying,
"They wouldn't believe me when I
said we couldn't come up with the
same high quality of scripts for a second year."
"Ralph, how could you do such a thing?"
"Humina humina humina –"
Gleason explained that he, quote, "wanted to go
out on top." The Honeymooners characters would
live on in specials and variety shows but
nothing would compare to those 39 episodes.
Gleason was nominated for an Emmy for his
portrayal of Ralph Kramden in the show. Did
he ever regret not making more? Co-star Art
Carney confided to the Corsicana Daily Sun,
"I think Gleason wishes he made 139 of them."
One of the best kids' game shows ever
made has been mostly forgotten to time.
I'm Telling ran on Saturday mornings for
a single season between 1987 and 1988.
Capitalizing on the popularity
of Nickelodeon's Double Dare,
producer Haim Saban came up with the
idea. He told the Los Angeles Times:
"We were looking for creative ways to
produce something different for children."
Saban added that there was an overabundance of
animated programming and his show was far
less expensive than a cartoon would be.
The format was similar to The Newlywed Game,
but here it was siblings who'd guess how the
other would answer a revealing question. The
winning pair advanced to the final round: the
Pick-A-Prize Arcade. Host Laurie Faso talked about
the show with the Detroit Free Press, saying,
"It's not demeaning to kids. It's not educational,
but there's no violence in it and it's
not going to hurt kids in any way."
There were a couple of celebrity
episodes of I'm Telling. In one,
Sean Astin appeared alongside his brother.
Other episodes featured then-unknown talents
like Paul Walker, Lindsay Price, and
Giovanni Ribisi. If you can find it,
you can relive the magic of I'm Telling
by scooping up a copy of the board game.
Importing a beloved British show is always a
risky proposition. For every The Office, there
are dozens of failures. But Arrested Development
writer/producer Brad Copeland saw potential in
the raunchy U.K. comedy The Inbetweeners, a
show about four teens who aren't as hip as
they'd like to be. Beginning in 2012, MTV rolled
out 12 episodes, some directed by Taika Waititi.
"We're gonna go on out there, and
we're gonna cause some havoc."
Critics and fans of the original weren't
willing to give it a chance to stand on
its own, and new viewers perhaps didn't
know what to make of it. But the U.S.
version produced its own brand of laughter,
especially when Zack Pearlman was involved.
Like the imported Skins before it, the
Inbetweeners remake never caught on in
America and soon got the ax. Pearlman
penned a goodbye on Tumblr, saying,
"I will always be able to look back at and
smile knowing that we did a fantastic job."
According to Joe Thomas of the U.K. version,
the American version was doomed from the
start as he explained to Sunday Brunch,
"They couldn't really swear very much
because it was on network TV. And
then you couldn't show them drinking and
stuff and that's kind of the whole show."
"Why do you smell like vomit and cheap alcohol?"
"It wasn't cheap. It had gold in it."
In 2005, the Globe and Mail pointed out
that three major networks would, quote,
"air new dramas about the United States under
attack from outside forces" that fall. NBC's
effort was Surface; CBS had Threshold; and
ABC went with the unidentified frightening
objects of Invasion. In an interview with Today,
Invasion creator Shaun Cassidy called the show,
"A suspense thriller in the bright sunlight."
Invasion takes place in the Everglades of Florida.
The story kicks off after a devastating hurricane,
when strange things start to occur.
Left behind in the destruction and
debris are two blended families who do
everything they can to stay dry and keep
their bodies from being snatched by the
unknown menace lurking in the wetlands.
William Fichtner, who played the town's shifty
sheriff, told the Lansing State Journal that
they wanted to end Season 1 with a twist:
the sheriff's wife, who's presumed dead,
was the mastermind all along. Unfortunately,
casting took too long, leaving the series with
a different, jarring cliffhanger that never got
resolved. Despite desperate pleas from fans,
who even flew a banner over ABC's headquarters,
no one could undo the cancellation.
When HBO's acclaimed series Rome fell
after two seasons, Scottish actor Kevin
McKidd looked around for a new project.
There were plenty of generic cop dramas,
but he was taken by the script for
Journeyman. He told the VC Star,
"I thought it was different and interesting
and really imaginative and cleverly
written. That's all you can go by."
The 2007 NBC series, created by Kevin
Falls, centers around McKidd's Dan Vasser,
a San Francisco journalist who travels back
in time to right wrongs for others, while
balancing the affections of his current flame
and his former partner, who is presumed dead.
Journeyman was compared to both
The Time Traveller's Wife and
Quantum Leap. And Entertainment Weekly called it:
"The awesome show the whole world is ignoring,
even though it's on right after Heroes."
Lukewarm ratings and a lengthy writers strike
combined to kill off the series. However,
when asked about the series sudden ending
by Entertainment Weekly, Falls said,
"We do answer quite a few questions so
fans will get a feeling of closure."
Falls admitted to The Hollywood Reporter that
he felt bad about upending McKidd's life,
uprooting his family and moving them to
the United States. However, he added,
"I'm relieved to say it turned into a pot
of gold. The next year [Kevin] started
his first of 10 seasons on Grey's
Anatomy. He also learned to surf."
When CBS rolled out its unique
and controversial reality series
Kid Nation in 2007, there were a lot
of concerned parents. The only adult
to be found in the ghost town of Bonanza
City, New Mexico was host Jonathan Karsh,
who stood on the sidelines and watched
as 40 kids fended for themselves for 40
days. The idea was to form a community without
descending into Lord of the Flies territory.
"Girls and boys of Bonanza City,
I'm sure we've all heard the term,
over and over again, 'Deal with it.'"
Even before the show premiered, bad press
haunted Kid Nation, largely due to the
agreement parents signed which prevented them
from suing even if their child died. Hollywood
reporter Nikki Finke loudly pleaded for the
network to yank the show from their slate,
and advertisers were initially hesitant
to promote their brands alongside it.
Regardless, CBS stood by Kid Nation defending
their care of the kids and even prepping a second
season. The show premiered to 9.4 million
viewers, proving popular with youngsters,
but the numbers dipped by the end of the
13-episode run and Season 2 never came to be.
The great thing about "Kid Nation" is
that it pushed its contestants to new
limits. Executive producer
Tom Forman told Variety,
"The part that was amazing and
controversial and groundbreaking was
the social element and the documentary
element as the kids figured it out."
Many of the kids have spoken fondly
about their time on the show,
which is now looked on as a fascinating TV relic.
The late writing duo Stan Burns and
Mike Marmer wrote for comedy greats
like Milton Berle, Steve Allen, The
Smothers Brothers, and Carol Burnett,
but perhaps their greatest unsung contribution
to television was a show that saw them go
completely ape. In an interview with the
Fort Worth Star-Telegram, Marmer recalled,
"It all started with the mad idea of
making a comedy spy movie with no people,
just chimps. We knew nothing about chimps or
even whether such a project was possible."
"Ooh. I just can't look. I can't believe my eyes!"
With help from animal trainer Frank
Inn, a ten-minute demo film was made,
and audiences went absolutely bananas over it.
ABC opened their Saturday morning cages to the
concept that eventually became 1970's
The Lancelot Link, Secret Chimp Hour.
The show centered on the titular
chimpanzee and his colleagues at A.P.E.:
Mata Hairi and Commander Darwin. They
attempted to thwart the monkey business
of C.H.U.M.P., with such rascally
characters as Baron von Butcher.
"This is the first step in my brilliant plan to
steal and dispose of the Star of Karachi diamond!"
The madness of watching these dressed-to-the-nines
chimps drive motorcycles, ski, and play tennis was
interspersed with small side gags called
"Chimpees," groovy musical interludes by
the band The Evolution Revolution,
and even some Looney Tunes shorts.
While Lancelot Link technically ran for
two seasons, the second was basically a
condensed version of the first. The
show would find a new generation of
fans when it naturally followed reruns of
The Monkees on Nick at Nite in the 1990s.
Life's Too Short is a hilarious one-season
show from Ricky Gervais and Stephen
Merchant. In a BBC press release,
Gervais described the show, saying,
"Life's Too Short is [a] naturalist
observational comedy, dealing with
everyday problems, human foibles and
social faux pas. But with a dwarf."
The lead role is played by Warwick Davis, who's
rarely been given the chance to show off his
comedic side. Over seven episodes that began
airing in 2011, Davis raised his eyebrows and
rolled his eyes alongside stars such as Johnny
Depp, Liam Neeson, Sting, Helena Bonham Carter,
and Steve Carell, while being supported in
clueless fashion by Gervais and Merchant.
"It's just really hard to act opposite
this, given the way it looks. I mean."
"Yeah, okay."
"I can't have its face staring at me like that."
The comedy was filled with memorable moments,
and Gervais had a ball working with Davis.
Davis told CNN that others in the
dwarf community appreciated it, saying,
"[They] find that this character
doesn't paint a rosy picture,
but paints more of a real picture in a sense."
"You're a dwarf. How can you
not know 'Hi ho, hi ho'?"
Gervais said a second season was on deck,
but it turned into a special in which Davis was
reunited with his Willow co-star Val Kilmer.
In the 1980s, NBC chief Brandon Tartikoff was
willing to take chances on shows that were a
bit off-kilter. While one of his pet projects,
Manimal, about a man who turns into animals,
didn't hit the mark, it didn't deter him
from trying similar things, like 1985's
Misfits of Science. The show followed a crew of
extraordinary people who drove around in an ice
cream truck. There was a scientist, a shrinking
man, an electrically charged Fonz-like guy,
and a telekinetic teen. Dean Paul Martin
and a young Courtney Cox were in the cast.
The gang not only had to battle dastardly bad
guys weekly but also the ratings-superpower that
was Dallas. The lackluster special effects made
the show cheesy yet endearing to young audiences,
who embraced it during its original run. The
plot seemed crazy for the time, but that was
before Marvel took over Hollywood. In a piece
about the show, The Salt Lake City Tribune wrote,
"It was about a bunch of people with super
powers, so maybe it was just ahead of its time."
NBC's Outsourced is a TV adaptation of a
feature film which follows a group of call
center workers in India. When Ken Kwapis, best
known for his work on The Office, saw the movie,
he asked the creators if he could pitch it
as a show. He told The Hollywood Reporter,
"My pitch was very simple: Whether
it's a paper company in Scranton, Pa.,
or a call center in Mumbai, the petty
foibles of office life are universal."
Clustered on a night of big NBC comedies
alongside The Office, 30 Rock, and Community,
Outsourced had a lot to live up to. And while
it didn't go down well with many critics,
those who liked it, raved about it. While some
said the show reinforced negative stereotypes,
writer Geetika Lizardi wrote
in a Los Angeles Times op-ed:
"The humor ultimately comes
from a place of affection."
Leslie Nielsen's The Naked Gun films are
considered to be some of the greatest
slapstick comedies of all time, but many people
don't realize that his detective character Frank
Drebin was in a TV show called Police Squad!
first. While promoting the hit movie Airplane!,
comedic masterminds Jim Abrahams and
the Zucker brothers watched a police
procedural show and knew immediately
that the genre was ripe for a parody.
"We would've come earlier, but
your husband wasn't dead then."
ABC gave the concept a six-episode trial,
seeing it as a possible replacement for
Mork & Mindy. Nielsen needed little
convincing to sign on, saying,
"I would have paid to be in this. I'm
on the same wavelength with these guys."
Puns and double entendres abounded. The
weekly guest star was usually killed off in
the opening credits, and those who did survive
– including Dick Clark, Dr. Joyce Brothers,
and Tommy Lasorda – sought professional advice
from an omniscient shoe shine man named Johnny.
"Johnny, some kids on the show
yesterday mentioned a new kind of music.
Ska. You know anything about it?"
Nielsen told the Minneapolis Star and Tribune,
"If ever there was a show that
I thought was going to be a hit,
this was it. [...] People
didn't know how to look at it."
One person who did get it was
Washington Post critic Tom Shales,
who called it "arguably the
best comedy show of the 1980s."
Patrick McGoohan made his name starring in
the series Danger Man, released in the U.S.
as Secret Agent. When he tired of the show,
he quit and moved on to what has become one
of the most influential shows of the 1960s:
The Prisoner. This fascinating one-season
British series follows an unnamed intelligence
agent being held captive in a creepy village.
"Where's the police station?"
"There isn't one."
"Can I use your phone?"
"We haven't got one."
The show was a metaphor for society at
large. McGoohan said in a 1977 interview,
"Your village may be different from other
people's villages but we are all prisoners."
The mind-bending series, which launched the
catchphrase: "Be seeing you," was shot at the
Welsh seaside. It featured cryptic villagers
decked out in mod fashions and the creepiest
ever use of a white meteorologist balloon.
It even captured the hearts of the Beatles,
so much so that they let the show use their song
"All You Need is Love" in an episode.
George Harrison's son Dhani told Wired,
"[It was] the only time a Beatles song
has ever been licensed to a TV show."
The 2010 thriller series Rubicon
is an overlooked gem. Speaking to
The Baltimore Sun, writer Henry Bromell said that,
"Rubicon was born out of the belief that
we in the United States could wake up one
day soon and find our democracy
gone, not vanquished by an army,
but by an almost invisible collusion
between business and government. I
know I'm not the only one who feels helpless
and powerless in the face of this collusion."
The show debuted to two million viewers,
which was a record for AMC at the time,
but it was soon eclipsed by a juggernaut called
The Walking Dead. The numbers didn't hold up,
and on a channel where Mad Men and Breaking Bad
made good, Rubicon became the walking dead itself.
In an interview with AV
Club, Bromell projected that
"[James Badge Dale] won't have to be doing
as much staring and thinking next season."
But it wasn't meant to be. Season 2 never
happened, and a great show was lost. In 2019, The
New York Times revisited the show in an article
headlined: "Ahead of Its Time, Rubicon Still Holds
Up." And Vulture's Vikram Murthi agreed in a piece
titled: "The Time Is Right to Rediscover Rubicon."
Inspired by the Pirates of the Caribbean ride at
Disneyland, the 1982 show Voyagers! is about a
time traveler named Phineas Bogg, played by
Jon-Erik Hexum, and a wise-beyond-his-years orphan
named Jeffrey Jones, played by Meeno Peluce. It
spelled out its premise in its opening credits:
"We travel through time to help history
along... give it a push where it's needed."
While the show took artistic liberties
with actual historical events,
it was all in the name of pleasing the target
audience. Peluce told The Columbia Record,
"In this show we roll up our sleeves,
dig right in and become part of
history. [...] It's every kid's fantasy to
participate in the great events in time."
Weaving through the ages, they cross paths, and
sometimes swords, with Cleopatra, Abraham Lincoln,
Lawrence of Arabia, Thomas Edison, Harry Houdini,
Charles Lindbergh, Robin Hood, and Kublai Khan.
The Washington Post hailed Voyagers!
as "a joy ride from start to finish,"
and the Citizens' Voice praised the show
for its "attempts both to entertain and
educate our children." Tragically, Hexum
died following an on-set incident with a
prop gun in 1984. This meant that a second
season of Voyagers! could never happen,
even if the network had wanted to make it.
NBC had already pulled the plug, however,
on account of the show struggling to go up
against 60 Minutes, which aired at the same
time. Voyagers! remains an '80s time capsule,
one that is definitely worth digging up.